good evening we start tonight with a
very tragic story out of the east valley
where two small
children are dead after a house fire
thanks for joining us here i'm denise
valdez and i'm christian casarez the
fire was on caddington avenue which is
near owens and hollywood
the two children that were killed were
about two months old
and two years old joe mueller is there
with the very latest joe any idea what
started the fire yet
we're supposed to get some more
information on that hopefully later on
but fire crews just left
the scene here they've been out here for
the entire day i'll give you a live look
down caddington now this is a closer
look that we've been getting throughout
the day you can see the home there on
the right side of the screen
you can see the front there the fire
damage to those windows
those two boys were found inside the
front of the home there in one of the
bedrooms
one man was also taken to the hospital
who was here on scene
crews got several calls from neighbors
of smoke coming from the home on
caddington avenue we were blocked from
the line of sight of the house for most
of the day due to the investigation
fire officials say they did not know if
anyone was inside with the kids at the
time
when they arrived they found a man
outside who was believed to be
attempting to help those kids inside now
fire investigators took over the scene
around noon and were out here throughout
the day trying to figure out how this
all started
started one room spread to another where
there were
two children one infant two months old
and
one toddler two years old both males
when crews found them it was obvious
that they were deceased
that man who was outside was transported
to the hospital with smoke related
injuries we do not know his relationship
to the kids it took crews about a half
an hour to get this fire under control
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the home where this all
happened fire crews said
it was in the front of the home and
spread to that bedroom where those two
young boys were inside now obviously
we're still waiting to find out the
cause of this blaze
a lot of family was out here throughout
the day very emotional also looking for
answers as well as soon as we
we are able to get an update on this
we'll be sure to pass it along
reporting live joe moeller 8 news now